then how does he play well sometimes as
Thompson dumps it how do these guys
achieve the level of consistency that he
had at his age how's that possible
listen I I
I've learned more basketball from
YouTube than anybody in my life but I I
think it on an older player to have to
Extended minutes a 38 year old all right
but he's 37. what about 36 older players
what about 35. no because that is it's
all it's always like that that like one
more day or you're old if you're 36 but
not 35
not every minute is is created equal
either absolutely but I just still think
it has it has an impact if you're
playing hard minutes
right but how many hard minutes did he
play tonight
do you think 32 no he played I would say
the first quarter wasn't especially
taxing I would say from that run in the
second quarter through the third quarter
was Taxi
I liked it better when you talked about
your nickname when you were seven
[Applause]
there's Peyton
it's like everybody's speculating Joel
embiid will not be able to play well
tomorrow because as Payton dunks at home
because he played 39 minutes and he's
Young
[Applause]
I mean it's just it's just
it's the crutch that we want to give to
certain people like it's hard to play
well in the NBA it's hard to win